among us uh
you're being told by lebron that he
thought you played a very good game do
you agree with him
i don't know i i think um
it was was an interesting um position uh
even though it was fairly symmetrical i
think um
the position is sharp uh because he has
a weak pawn potentially and
um if
you know not if he doesn't have an
attack then i'm better so i think he
went for the right approach giving up
two minor pieces for
two pawns and a rook after that i
thought it was better at first but
probably i wasn't i think it was fairly
equal maybe even slightly better for him
anyway i think she um missed a couple of
my moves later on uh and then i was
much better to winning um
and then yeah right at the end i'm
quite a little bit confused
and i got short of time but i think i
was winning
uh gm ramirez here on the side was
saying it's magnus doing magnus things
in this game and it was a very typical
game for you do you agree with that
i don't know what is a typical game for
for me um but it was it was like just a
nice complicated
game we both were playing for win for a
win and eventually i got all the chances
good luck thank you